[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه الكرام
قرارا تاريخيا بامتياز لاول مره لم يعد
الارهاب محصورا بالعربي والمسلمين الا
يستحق النظام الروسي بقياده بوتن ان يكون
على راس القوى الارهابيه في العالم بعد
المحارق التي يقترفها في اوكرانيا وسوريا
وليبيا وافريقيا ومن قبل في الشيشان
يتساءل البعض
المتصفح عصابه فاجنر الروسيه التابعه
للكريمنس شقيقه لابشع العصابات الارهابيه
في العالم الا يعتبر الرئيس الروسي اكبر
داعما للجماعات والاحزاب الفاشيه المتطرفه
في الغرب فلم يصبح الجيش الروسي وميلي
شاته مختصرا بحرق المدن والابرياء وتهجير
ملايين البشر من المدنيين حسره
لكن في المقابل هل يحق للغرب المرطخه يداه
بدمائي ملايين البشر ايتهم الروسي
بالارهاب الا تعمل روسي على تنظيف المناطق
التي لوثتها امريكا بالخراب والارهاب
لماذا كلما تعارضت مصالح دوله ما مع
المصالح الغربيه سارع الغربيون الى تلفيق
تهمه الارهاب للاخرين هل تختلف اساليب
اوروبا عن اساليب المخابرات العربيه التي
تلفق تهم الارهاب لمعارضيها وهي اكبر
ارهابيا في التاريخ الا تدافع روسي عن
امنها القومي في اوكرانيا ولا تمارس
الارهاب مطلقا الم تحارب الجماعات
الارهابيه في سوريا وغيرها اسئله اطرحها
من موسكو على الدكتوره الاكاديميه ثري
الخبيره في سياسه الخارجيه الروسيه ومن
باريس على الدكتور محمد هنيد الاستاذ في
جامعه السوربون
نبدا نقاش بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم
في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس دكتور
باريس
تطور تاريخي الى صح التعبير غير مسبوق
لاول مره لم يعد الارهاب محصورا بالعربي
والمسلمين واحده من دول العالم العظمى
روسيا الان اصبحت مصنفه راعيه للارهاب من
قبل الاوروبيين ماذا يعني ذلك
نعم شكرا على استضافه دكتور فيصل
الهم جدا كما ذكرت انت هو قرار تاريخي
لاول مره لماذا بقطع النظر عن قدره
الاجرائيه هل لديه استتباعات ام لا لكن هو
هام جدا من جهه انه ينزع اولا
حصريته تهمه الارهاب على العرب والمسلمين
يعني لم يعد العرب والمسلمون الذين يعني
طوال المده الاخيره منذ تقريبا سنوات 79
عندما وضعت الخارجيه الامريكيه اول لائحه
او قائمه لتصنيف المنظمات الارهابيه او
الدول الارهابيه وضعت عليها العراق واليمن
الجنوبي في تاريخه وليبيا الى غير ذلك
اصبح اصبح التصنيف وهو تصنيف اوروبي
للامانه ضد همم
الاتحاد الروسيا اذا هذا المنعرج يؤكد ان
ظاهره الارهاب اليوم تخرج عن دائرتها
العربيه الاسلاميه وتتجه نحو قوه غربيه
خلقت يعني كان صانع او طابخ ثم سيذوق منه
يعني ينقلب السحر على الساحر هذا هام جدا
لانه ينزح هذه الصفه على العرب والمسلمين
ويشير الى الفاعلين الدوليين الحقيقيين
بما يسمى ارهاب دوله وليس ارهاب تنظيمات
بالنسبه لروسيا والالتهاب الاوروبي
المواجهه اليها في خلال السنوات الاخيره
اظهرت انها تحولت الى دوله ارهابيه
بامتياز لم نتحدث عن دوره العصابات التي
تطور اليها الاتحاد السوفياتي بعد انهياره
في التسعينات وخروج منها افغانستان عندما
قام بمذابح لا يمكن وصفها في الشيشان في
الحرب الشيشانيه الاولى والثانيه ما خلفه
الى اليوم في افغانستان من 20% من الاراضي
الافغانيه ما زالت تحمل الالغم الارضيه ما
قام به من غابحه من براميل وقذف عشوائي
وقفت على الهويه في سوريا وانت اعلم مني
بذلك والاخوه السوريين ما قامت به جماعات
ليبيا وخاصه خلال الهجمه الاخيره على
طرابلس 2019 من تفقيق المنازل والقتل
العشوائي والقتل على الهويه وراينا كيف
تفننت مجموعه فاجنر هاتي في وضع الدمى
والعاب الاطفال حين يعود المدنيون الى
الديارهم فتنفجر وتقتل منهم وقتلت منهم
العشرات الان ماذا حدث استفاق الغرب اليوم
او الغرب الاوروبي على عوده الدب الروسي
وعوده كوابيس الحرب البارده وكانه يريد ان
يستعيد المجال الذي يعتقد انهم توزيع منه
يعني خلال الحرب بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ماذا حدث استراتيجيه
اوروبا الغربيه وقعت تحت الوصايه
الامريكيه مباشره اوروبا الوسطى الوسطى
بدات في السنوات الاخيره تتجه نحو الغرب
عبر ما يسمى بتوسعه الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
27 دوله الحاصل اليوم هو ان بوتيل لا يريد
للاتحاد الاوروبي ان يتمدد نحو اوكرانيا
قالوا لا يعني الوريث الشرعي للاتحاد
السوفيتي ماذا حول كيف حول او الى ماذا
حول روسيا حاول روسيا الى دوله عصابات
لاننا عندما نرى ان طباخ بوتين هو همم هو
هو قائد او زعيم الذي اعترف مؤخرا مجموعه
فاجنر ما هي جماعه قتل ومرتزقه ارهابيه
يمكن ان نفهم طبيعه الدوله الى ماذا تحولت
يعني تحولت الى دوله اصابات روسيا الان
تريد ان تحيي هذا الحلم القديم وانا
تستطيع ان تعود بقوه الى الساحه الدوليه
وانها ان تستطيع ان تناسي حينها لا تملك
اي امكانيات ثم تمتلكه الدول الغربيه
وخاصه الاوروبيه يعني لا لا لا لا يمكن ان
نحسب لروسيا اي انجاز ثقافي اي انجاز في
الفن اي انجاز صناعي اي انجاز في الادب كل
ما تملكه روسيا وتنتجه هو اما النفط
والغاز او الاسلحه والات الدمار والموت
حول العالم جميل جدا طيب دكتوراه كيف
تردين على هذا الكلام الدكتور يقول يعني
فعلا تطور تاريخي بامتياز ان تصبح دوله
عظمى عضو في مجلس الامن الدولي عضو في
مجلس الامن الدولي مصنفه دوله ارهابيه
يعني كيف سيتتصرفون الان يعني داخل مجلس
الامن المسؤول عن الامن في العالم هناك
دوله مصنفه راعيه للارهاب
يسعد مساك دكتور فيصل والضيفك الكريم
والجمهور الذي احبه واحترمه دائما
في البدايه ولكن في البدايه لو سمحت استاذ
فيصل تعطيني الوقت الكافي ولا تقاطعني
ودعني اتحدث عن فكره بشكل كامل كل الشكر
من الشعر بيت انت وضيفك من من باريس ليس
هذا فقط يعني ليس فقط ما اتخذه البرلمان
الاوروبي والذي امتنعت لم يصوت بالاجماع
يعني هناك دول امتنعت اا ومن اهمها فرنسا
عندما خرج ماكرون وقال هذا ليس من شان
البرلمان الاوروبي هذا يعود الى محكمه
العدل الدوليه والجرائم الدوليه هي التي
تصنف ونحن ليسنا اساسا مخولين بهذه
المساله ال- ال- الاضافي ايضا بالنسبه الى
قرار البرلمان الاوروبي هو ما اتخذه
البندستاد الالماني من همم
كبار بان مجاعه هولور
بانها ترتقي الى اباده جماعيه ارتكبتها
ارتكبها يومها الاتحاد السوفيتي بحق الشعب
الاخراني علما بان هذه المساله تعود الى
100 عام تعود الى 100 عام الى المساله هنا
وتعني فقط اقارن يعني الان ما يحدث هو
عباره ايضا عندما يستخدمون مساله محارق
الهالوكوس انما استخدمها اسرائيل ضد ما
يسمى معادات الساميه ايضا عندما يستخدم
اوروبا وتستخدم واشنطن ورقه ال- ايباده
الارمن من قبل الاتراك اذا هي عباره هذه
كلها تاتي ادوات في سياق الصراعات
والمناكفات السياسيه الهدف منها الضغط على
الطرف الاخر يعني عندما تريد الدول ان
تعمى بصرها عن جرائم ارتكبت بحق الانسانيه
هي تصاب بالعمى وعندما تريد ان تفتح
اعينها وتبصر من جديد هي تلقي الضوء على
ما يسمى ارهاب هذه النقطه اذا هذا كله
ياتي في اطار الدعايه السياسيه المؤقته
لماذا الان اوروبا على شفاء انهيار
اقتصادي هي تعاني شعوب اوروبا تخرج
مظاهرات في الامس خرجت مظاهرات في المانيا
في براج في برلين تطالب الحكومه الالمانيه
بان تكف عن ان تكون دميه بيد واشنطن وبيد
الناتو خرجت مظاهرات في النمسا خرجت
مظاهرات في في المجر في التشيك كل هذه
خرجت مظاهرات تطالب الحكومات حتى في
التشيك طلبت الشعوب الجماهير تخرج مظاهرات
باستقاله الحكومه وانه اعتبرت بان هذه
الحكومات هي تتامر على الشعوب الاوروبيه
لماذا خرج البرلمان الاوروبي المهزوم في
هذا الادعاء نعلم بان الان كما ذكرت لك
اوروبا تعاني المشاكل تعاني من انهيار
الاقتصاديه غلاء المعيشه ال- ال- الضغط
الذي يعيش تحته المواضع الاوروبي ماذا
تقول هذه الحكومات تقول تحاول قدر الامكان
ان تع نوع من اوبر المورفين لشعوبها وتقول
لها اصموا واصبروا وصابروا نحن نحارب
الارهاب وها نحن اليوم نقول عن روسيا
الدوله الراعيه للارهاب يعني كما خرج
الرئيس ماكرون على الشعب الفرنسي وقال لهم
لقد ذهب عهد الرفاهيه عليكم ان تشد الحزام
وكاننا نعود الى الدول العربيه ومساله شد
الحزام اذا هي عباره عن دعايه في اطار في
اطار ال- ال- الاعلان هي عباره عن دعايه
في اطار الاعلان المؤقت هدفها كما قلت لك
تهدئه الشعوب الاوروبيه التي اصبحت حقيقه
ترزح تحت النيل العقوبات الغربيه التي
بدات تقتل الشعب الاوروبيه اكثر من ما
تقتل الان الشعوب الشعب الاخراني والشعب
الروسي من ضغوط عليه المساله الاخرى ما
قامت به قناه فوكس نيوز الامريكيه نعلم
بان هذه القناه لديها شعبيه واسعه في
اوروبا وايضا في امريكا عندما خرجت برامج
قامت هذه البرامج بينشر وثائق رسميه مسربه
عن اعداد
مليارات والملايين التي يقوم زيرينسكي
بالشراء فلل ش همم فارغه في سويسرا
والسيارات وقالت بالحرف الواحد يومها
المقدمه للاسف اعذرني دكتور فيصل نسيت اسم
المذيعه ولكن لا ادري ما هي الفاميلي لها
عندما قالت لن نحن نتعب ونشقى وتذهب
نقودنا وفلوسنا بالضرائب الى ذلك اللص
ونعتت ذينيسكي على شاشه فوكس نيوز بانه
اذا هي عباره عن قرار انتقائي
تستخدمه الدول عندما تشاء وتنفيه عندما
تشاء
طيب سنعود الى الدكتوره الدكتور محمد
الكثير من الكلام المهم في واقع الامر
يعني الدكتوره ثريا تقول لك يجب ان لا
نعلق الكثير من الاهميه على مثل هذا
القرار هو ليس قرارا تاريخيا ابدا هو مجرد
دعايه سياسيه مؤقته قرار انتقائي محاوله
مفتوحه لتهدئه الشعوب الاوروبيه ولا يمكن
التعويل عليه باي حال من الاحوال كيف ترد
الدكتور
اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ذلك لماذا اسباب بسيطه
لاول مره في تاريخ التصنيفات الارهابيه
يصنف كما ذكرت ان دكتور فيصل يعني دوله
صاحبه فيتو في مجلس الامن بقوه روسيا بقوه
الاتحاد السوفيتي الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
بقوه نفوذه في العالم بقوه مخابرات
السؤال بالنسبه للاستاذ الفاضله
الدول العربيه التي لا يعني الشعوب
العربيه او اي مواطن في العالم لا يهاجر
او لا يذهب الى روسيا هو يذهب الى الدول
اوروبا الغربيه لماذا نحن نذهب الى دول
اوروبا
دكتور تفضلي
نعم نعم نعم
بنسبه الى القرار هو لا يستند الى اطار
عمل قانوني يعني ما يقوله ضيفك الكريم
يعني هذا عباره عن كلام اييه
[موسيقى]
للتداول فقط
لا يستند الى اطار قانوني ايضا الاهم
فيه يعني
يكفيني بان الرد الامريكي امريكا وهي
الراعيه لهذه الحرب الان التي تجري ما بين
روسيا واوكرانيا امريكا والخارجيه
الامريكيه رفضت هذا القرار واعتبرته نوع
من من من من من من من ال- ال- ال- الغباء
او عدم التغير وقالت على العكس بان هذا
الغباء بان هذا التصرف وهذا اعلان سياتي
بنتائج عكسيه ان كان هدفكم الضغط او اخراج
همم الجيش الروسي من داخل من اوكرانيا هذا
لن يتم احنا العكس وصفت هذا بانه سياتي
بنتائج عكسيه هناك ملفات مشتركه ما بين كل
من اوروبا واشنطن وروسيا هي عالقه لا يمكن
التخلي او الخروج عنها وبالنسبه الى تصنيف
الدول الراعي الارهاب نعلم بان هناك اربع
دول هي ليست ليست جميع الدول الاسلاميه
هناك اربع دول صنفت بانها راعي الارهاب من
ضمنها كوبا ومن ضمنها ايضا رؤيه
الان ان اردت يا دكتور فيصل ان نتحدث نعم
ان اردت يا دكتور فيصل ان نتحدث بنسبه الى
متى الشيشان دعني ارد على ضيفه الكريم من
باريس بالنسبه الى مساله الشيشان الم يكن
جورج واشنطن الزعيم الوطني القومي هو من
اشد المعادين للانفصاليين عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الم يقم ابراهيم لينكون
ايضا الزعيم الوطني بالنسبه للامريكيين
باستعاده جميع الاراضي الانفصاليه بقوه
السلاح وقاده حربا ضد الانفصاليا هل هو
مجرم
الراحله بالضغط على نيوزيلندا وايرلندا
وحربت الجيش الجمهوري الايرلندي حتى تبقى
تلك التابعه تلك المناطق تابعه تحت التاج
الملكي اذا لماذا لماذا نكتيلين ان اردتني
يا دكتور فيصل ان نتحدث عن الارهاب دعنا
نتحدث عن الارهاب منطقيه واقعيه سابدا ان
ستحدث عن الارهاب وسابدا قطر سابدا للتحدث
عن الارهاب من قطر الان ما تعرضت له دوله
قطر بعد تنظيمها لهذا المونديال بهذه
الطريقه الرائعه عندما قامت دعوات فرنسيه
ودعوات اوروبيه لمقاطعه المونديال لمجرد
بانه في قطر وخرجت دعوات تقول ثمن هذه قطر
هي لا تكاد ان ترى حتى على الخريطه
الدوليه ولماذا يستضاف مونديال علمي في
دوله مثل هذه اليس هذا ارهاب عندما نتحدث
ويخرج تقرير جون كلكم عن غزو العراق ويقول
لك ضمن الاطار القانوني وليس ضمن
الانتقائيه التي خرج بها البرلمان
الاوروبي عندما يخرج عليك في تقرير غزو
العراق ويقول لك مستندا الى الاطار
القانون الدولي بان ما حدث في العراق هو
جريمه دوليه يخالف القانون الدولي ما حدث
من جرائم في سجن ابو غريب وما قامت به
المجندات الامريكيات من اغتصاب للشباب
العراق وقتل العراقين داخل سجن ابو غريب
ارهاب عندما قامت جنود الامريكان بحرق
واغتصاب طفله عمرها 12 عاما وحرقها وحرقه
عائلتها اليس اغتصاب عندما يقوم
اسرائيليين بقتل الشعب الفلسطيني تقرير
جولد ستون الاخير الذي خرج وصنف وقال جولد
ستول وهو يهودي عندما خرج بتقرير دولي
وقال بان ما يحدث في غزه هو يرقى الى
مستوى
جميل جدا جميل جدا
دكتور بس خليني اقاطعك بس خليني يقاطعك
ثاني بس الدكتور محمد يعني لو عدت من من
الدكتوره انه في نفس النقطه بنفس النقطه
انه هذا الكلام او هذا التصنيف الاوروبي
لروسي على انها دوله راعيه للارهاب في وقع
القمر ليست ذات اهميه ابدا ابدا قال قدمت
لنا الكثير من الشواهد بما فيها الرفض
الامريكي اللي مثل هذه الخطبه كيف ترد
نعم يا دكتور فيصل انا لا اختلف مع
الاستاذه الفاضله في تصنيف جورج بوش
وتاكشر وبلار وكل عصابات هذه في انها
مجاميع ارهابيه لكن نميز منهجيا بين
التصنيف الامريكي والتصنيف الاوروبي قلنا
بالنسبه لمن يرى ان شكل الاطلسي او الغربي
هو كتله موحده فهو يعني الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يحاول ان تبقي هيمنتها على
القاره الاوروبيه خاصه الغربيه وهناك مساء
غربيه خاصه من جهه المانيا وفرنسا لمحاوله
انشاء جيش اوروبي مش والخروج من تعقيبها
الامريكيه يعني امريكان لا تريد ان تدين
هذا القرار ان توافق على هذا القرار لانه
يديرها في شكل ما وهي تشتغل باوروبا عن
طريق
بيشتغل بالوكاله للراعيه الامريكاني من
ناحيه الناحيه الثانيه وهو انني انا او
كمواطن عربي او كي نبقى
في ليبيا وفي روسيا والقتل الذي حدث وانا
اعتبر نفسي روسي وليبي لانني سكس بيكو هو
اجرام يرتقي او حتى يتجاوز ما تقوم به
الاصابات الامريكيه ما الفرق بين الذن
الروسيه وبين داعش او بقيه الفصائل
الايرانيه المسلحه التي اثرت في دماء
الشعب السوري هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى
كيف لي ان ارى هذه المجازر والمذابح ولا
استبشر خيرا بهذا التصنيف على الاقل ان
يذوق طابخ ثم اضخم من ناحيه اخرى اريد ان
اذكر الاستاذه الفاضله بان التصنيفات
الصادره لروسيا تصنيفات صابره عنها وهي
تصنيفات او ردتها صحيفه روتاسيا غزال سنه
2008 على ما اعتقد وفيها
تصلي اسلامي كلها الكيانات اسلاميه بما
فيها الاخوان المسلمون بما فيها جمعيه
حمايه تراث الكويتيه بما فيها جندي الشام
يعني الروسيا او الجيش الروسي اختصاصه في
العربيه هي الكيانات الاسلاميه او
المكونات الاسلاميه اذا هو بيصنف الاخرين
على انهم الارهابيون قام بقصف الاطفال
في يوم عندما يتم تصنيف الجيش الروسي
ونظام الروسي على اساس انه نظام وكنان
وجيش ارهابي يستنقل الجماعه ويقول لك لا
الغرب
انا مفروغ منه وانا جورج بوش مجرم حرب
وقاتل وابو غريب وفلسطين وفي كل ذلك لكن
لا يعني ذلك ولا يحجب ذلك عني جرائم روسيا
وجرائم الجيش الروسي وجرائم نظام ملازم
الكوتين في المنطقه العربيه اذن اليوم
عندما نريد ان نغطي الارهاب الروسي بالقول
هناك الارهاب اخر ولارهاب الامريكي او
الغربي فهنا لا يعرف ثم
الاخ
رى تقول فيصل هو ان تحالف الانظمه العربيه
قد يكون مفهوم مع الاجرام الروسي والاجرام
الايراني القوميون العرب مثلا دكتور فيصل
اليوم وهم نقطه لاطلاق المشروع الصفوي
والمشروع الروسي في المنطقه العربيه
السلام عليك يا حاج سلبياتي في الخمسينات
والستينات والسبعينات
اشتراكيه شيعيه في المنطقه العربيه ومنطقه
غير ذلك لم يقدموا الامه اي شيء باستثناء
اسناد الطغاه والمسلمين
ذلك منولات القوميه العربيه البعثيه
والناصريه والقويله غير ذلك كانت تستمد
قوتها من نظام روسي ماذا قدم لها الروس
وثقف لا شيء قدم لهم فقره الاسلحه لقشره
شعوبهم والقضاء عليه اخرهم اليوم
وهو يتفرج
على الساحل القرن بشار الاسد السوريين حلف
معهم حزب الله التنظيم الابرص في لبنان
يعني كل هذه الكيانات هي الكيانات دقيقه
ضمن الشعوب العربيه ضمن ثوره العربيات
هي والكرامه لهذه
الامه على الاخر الموقل الامريكي اليوم
وموقف متحرك يقول الجماعه ايضا سنفور
الروس كان عاملين سيصنفونني غدا كارهاب
ولابد ان نترك هذه المساله حصريا العرب
والمسلمين وان لم نستعملها في ما بيننا
جميل جدا دكتوره كيف تردين على هذا الكلام
يعني الدكتور يقول نحن لا نختلف معك بان
لا يحق لا لا الاوروبيين ولا للامريين ان
يصنف الروس على انهم ارهابيون لكن يعني
همم هذا لا يغطي هذا الكلام لا يغطي على
ان الروس ارهابيون فعلا يعني بالكثير من
الدلائل
الدكتور فيصل طبعا بنسبه الى الدكتور محمد
لا ادري لماذا يستند وللاسف يعني لما
استمع جيدا لما قاله لان الصوت بالنسبه لي
ابدا غير واضح فانا لم استمع لما قاله
ولكن فقط نبقى في دائره الارهاب وانت لم
تعطيني الوقت الكافي لاتحدث لك عن معنى
الارهاب وما معنى الارهاب ساتحدث فقط عن
الموقف الاخير للوزيره الالمانيه التي هي
من ضمن المانيا من ضمن الناس التي ادرجت
هذا التسميه عندما تحايلت على القانون
الدولي بنسبه الى منظمه فيفا عندما لم
تقوم باحترام القانون والسياده دوله قطر
ووضعت شعار المثليين على يدها وردت ستره
وعندما دخلت داخل الملعب الاستاذ قامت
بخلع الستره واظهرت المجتمع للمشاهد
العربي المسلم والجاليات الاخرى بانها هي
تساند ووضعت شعار حب واحد انا هذا ما
اسميه ارهاب يعني من من المفرح جدا ان
تقوم دول مثل هذه بانتقاد رو عندما تقوم
وزير الداخليه الدوله بانتهاك القانون
هل لي ان اعتب على هذه الدوله عندما تقوم
وزير الداخليه انت وزير الداخليه تقومين
بالتحايل على الدوله القطريه تقومين
باحتقار للدوله القطريه اظهار هذا الشعار
الا يعني بان نحن العرب وانتم كدوله قطر
متخلفين لا تعطون للناس حقوقهم او احترام
المثليين عندما تخرج بعد ذلك الشاشات
التلفاز التلفزيونيه الالمانيه وتصف
المجتمع القطري والمجتمع العربي بانه
مجتمع متخلف لم يستوعب الى الان معنى
المثليين عندما تقوم امريكا بالضغط على
المملكه العربيه السعوديه اللي ضخ ان
النفط ولانها امتنعت عن زياد دخل النفط
وتهديدها من قبل السيناتورات الامريكيين
بان يجب ان يعاقب السعوديه على هذه
المساله لا ادري هل هي السعوديه الولايه
رقم 51 كتاب الامريكيه النظام يا دكتوره
لماذا لم تصنف اسرائيل لماذا لم تصنف
اسرائيل رايت ارهاب لماذا لم يتم تسليط
الضوء على صبره وشاتيلا لماذا ينحاز ضيفك
دائما الجانب الغربي لماذا الان تعد ماسي
مدى عليها مجاعه هولو دمار مضى عليها اكثر
مئه عام وان كانت روسيا ان تريد ان استخدم
حصار سنغراد ايضا لقد راح يجراه لا يقل عن
20 مليون روسي جراء هذا الحصان لماذا لم
تذكر لماذا ن كيلو بمكيالين الان ما قال
لي بان لا يوجد مهاجرين الى روسيا هذا غير
صحيح عدد الجاليات العربيه المتواجده في
روسيا عالي جدا ولكن روسيا لديها قانون
تطلب من خلاله الهجره واللجوء الى روسيا
روسيا لن تقوم باعتقال الاطفال كما فعل
السوسيال في السويد لم تاخذ الاطفال ال-
ال- راينا الفيديو الاخير الذي تشرع في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بعد اخذ الطفله
السوريه من المدرسه السابقه الطفله
السوريه من امام المدرسه من قبل السوسيا
السويدي عندما قامت بالاتصال خلسه باخيها
وقالت له انا اتصل بكم
اشتقت اليكم وانا اتكلم معكم خلفه عن
السوسيال روسيا لم تسرق الاطفال روسيا لم
تخطف الاطفال روسيا لن تروج المثليين
روسيا لم تقم بارتكاب صبرا وشاتيلا من
روسيا لم تقم يوميا بقصف ما يسمى اسرائيل
الان تقوم يوميا او ما يمكن بين يوم ويوم
بقصف سوريا تحت اي ذريه تحت اي حجه انا
اقول لك لماذا اوكرانيا اوكرانيا ان
اوكرانيا هي الجزء الغربي من مملكه الخزر
اليهوديه ونعلم بان بعد عام 2000 في عام
2014 عندما قام الانقلاب ضد حكومه
ينكوفيتش وصعد اليمين المتطرف والجميع
يعلم اذا عدتم ما قراتم عن كيف الجميع
يعلم بان هناك ست وزراء يهود في ال- ال-
الحكومه همم
الاوكرانيه ونعلم هؤلاء جميعا انصار ستبن
بانديرا الذي حارب مع النازيين الالمان
ايام الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهذه حقائق
ان كنت بدي اتكلم نسبتي الى الوثائق اذا
المساله انتقائيه المساله الانتقاليه انت
الى ما حدث في سوريا لولا التواجد الروسي
لك كانت الان سوريا كل حاره عليها زعيم
داعشي غزو العراق وباعتراف من توني بلير
الم يؤدي الى ظهور تنظيم الجماعات
الارهابيه الم يخلق لنا تنظيم داعش
والنصره وغيره وهذا اعتراف ليس مني ولم
تقله موسكو هذا باعتراف طوني بلير عندما
قالوا بان هذا هو تقرير لجنه همم الذي
قالت كل هذا ادى الى انهيار الشرق الاوسط
وظهور التنظيمات الارهابيه اذا من الذي
يرعى الارهاب بريطانيا التي تحتوي الان
الجماعات الارهابيه من حزب الاخوان
المسلمين حتى اخر الاحزاب الاخرى واخره
فلندا التي تحتوي حزب البيكي المحظور
دوليا هي والسويد اذا لا تحدثون عن
المبادئ والاخلاق وانتم اشجار الغربي
عندما تقوم وزير الداخليه وزير الداخليه
للدوله المانيا تنتهي كالقانون هلا علي
انا احترم مثل هذا القانون جميل جدا جميل
جدا
اضيف صوتي الى صوت وزير الخارجيه لافروف
نعم جميل جدا دكتور كيف ترد
نعم كبير من المعطيات
الاستاذ لكن منهجيا تحليليا انا لست هنا
ان اختار بين الطاعون والكوليرا
يعني يريدون ان يغطي الطاعون بالكوليرا
وهذا غير ممكن ذكرت الاستاذه ان الاخوان
المسلمون تنظيم ارهابي هذا التصنيف الروسي
الاخوان المسلمين
المسلمين لا يسمحون للحكم او المعارضه لكن
القول انهم تنظيم ارهابي هذا مجافي
للحقيقه ولا غير صحيح عندما قالت الاستاذه
الفاضله ان لولا التدخل الروسي لكان في كل
حرده واحده سيدتي هذا سخريه ورقص على دمشق
سوريا الذي خرج من اجل الحريه
تفاحه ارهابيات ومقادي في سوريا ضد شعب
سوريا من مغابح من العار ان نصمت عن ذلك
من العالم ان نصمط على القتل في ليبيا
نعمل السوري ذبح الاطفال اسالي اطفال حلب
ودير الزور وجسر الثغور ومعره النعمان
اسال للاحياء سوريا ماذا فعل المجرم
السوري من الروسي من طرطوس ومن حميمين
وعندما تحول الحمار الروسي حافظ الاسد
بشار الاسد الى غلام امام القاده الروس
الروس مستعمرون مشتالون هناك مثل ما كان
الامريكيون في العراق فلا نخلط على الحامل
من نابل ونغطي عن هذا بذلك عندما تقول اني
اين الق
يم الغمامه عن القيم الروسيه روسيا الدوله
بوليسيه لاحظ فيها لمعارضه فيها
[موسيقى]
السلعوه دمار
اليوم
دوله ارهابيه لمعرفه التصنيف لماذا لانه
يضع قاتل اهلي في سوريا وفي ليبيا
والمسلمين في كل مكان
ظنث هذا القاتل المجرم الذي يملك اسلحه
اناويه ارسنال ضخمه لم يجرب السوريين
عندما نغذي ذلك بالقول ان الغرب لي
ست يغطي عن جرائم الروس جرائم الامريكان
وكلاء هم في الاجرام سواء الارهاب
الامريكي مساوي للارهاب الروسي
اكثر
الاطفال اكثر بالعزه يعني لا يستثني الروس
احدا وراء اين جرائم كيف نغطي عن جرين في
الشيشان في افغانستان في ليبيا في
جمهوريات اوروبا الشرقيه كلها لكي نقول لا
والله
انا
لا اعرف والجرائم التي قام بها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه قامت بخاصه في العراق
اسرائيل ما يقوم بانكيام الصهيوني في ارض
فلسطين لكن القول يعني نقفز
علامه الشعب السوري لولا تدخل الروس لا
كان هناك داعش في كل حركه الدواعش صنعه
النظام حافظ الاسد والنوري المالكي من
العراق
صناعه المخابرات العسكريه انا اريد ان
اسالك يا استاذ ان كنت تشاهدتي شهران ايسر
ان كنت شهد السوريين الذين قتلوا في سوريا
في سجون الحاضر اشراب المخابرات الروسيه
التي كانت هناك تشرف على عمليه التعذيب
والقتل والاختصار والتصفيه الجسديه
والاختيار القسري والمقابر الجماهير
في تاريخ روسيا الكره التاريخ وسيصرفهم
باعتبارهم مجرم حرب ضد الانسانيه ما حدث
اباده جماعيه واباده لثوره شعب سوريا
الشعب السوري ليس شعبانيه ارهابيا شعب
ليبيا ليس شعبانا ارهابيا هي شعوب مسالمه
ان تنتصر الحريه والكرامه وان المفعول به
الى رتبه الكرامه الانسانيه مثل الدول
الاخرى لكن كان الرؤوس هناك بالمرصاد
لحمايه وكيل
في المنطقه دكتوره كيف تردين على هذا
الكلام خاصه وانه يعني قبل قليل ذكر ال-
ال- ال- المجموعه الروسيه الشهيره فاجنر
وقال يعني هل يمكن باي حال من الاحوال ان
نميز هذه الجماعه عن داعش او عن بقيه
الميليشيات التي تعيث خرابا وفسادا
وارهابا في المنطقه
نعم فقط الاستاذ الفاضل من فرنسا الدكتور
محمد هو يناقد نفسه عندما قال بان روسيا
هي تتبنى حزب الاخوان المسلمين يعني هو
منذ قليل
لم يقل ذلك
بان روسيا تحتوي حزب الاخوان المسلمين
روسيا تحتوي الاخوان المسلمين الاسلام
نعم
قلت لك عندي مشكله نعم طيب بالنسبه الى
التنظيمات الارهابيه هذا لم تذكر روسيا
وما ذكره طوني بلير اذا من اوجد داعش
والتنظيمات الاخرى وهذا باعتراف من رئيس
الوزراء السابق البريطاني توني بلير عندما
خرج للشعب العراقي الذي فقد ما يقارب اكثر
من اربع ملايين او خمس ملايين قتلوا تحت
القزم وغزو 30 33 دوله من ضمنهم القيم
الغربيه الاوروبيه التي تدافع عنها الذين
قاموا بغزوه الدوله
عزباء لا تملك اسلحه الدمار من ضمنها تلك
الدول الغربيه التي ذات القيم الانسانيه
التي تذكرها حضرتك طيب
لا يعارض
الغربي هو متفق معك لكن
دقيقه بس دقيقه
تربيع يا دكتوره تتحدثين عن الارهاب
الامريكي في العراق وقتل العراقيين وتشريد
العراقيين وتدمير البنيه التحتيه العراقيه
لا يختلف معك الدكتور بس بس خليني اكمل لك
بس خليني بس خليني خليني اخلص سؤالي بس يا
دكتوره يا دكتوره ماذا فعل الروس في
افغانستان في 79
هل تعلمين ان الروس قتلوا مليون افغاني
وهجروا خمسه ملايين افغاني لا احد يتحدث
عنهم
مليونير افغاني قتلهم الاتحاد السوفيتي
الروس الروس اذن الارهاب الروسي
نعم تفضلي
طيب طيب يا دكتور فيصل المساله اين انا
اقول لك خذ عشر ملايين افغاني قتلوا اوكي
روسيا ليست هي الاتحاد السوفيتي انا لا
انكر بان بالتاكيد الاتحاد السوفيتي ارتكب
خطا انا لا ادافع عن الاتحاد السوفيتي
بالتاكيد ونعلم بان هناك كانت اصوات صوفيا
روسيه من الداخل تعارض هذا الغزو السوفيتي
الى افغانستان لا ننكر بان هذا خطا تاريخي
في تاريخ الاتحاد السوفيتي عندما قام بغزو
افغانستان وكانت هناك اصوات حتى تعار من
داخل الحزب الشيوعي بان تقوم بان يقوم
الاتحاد السوفيتي بغزوا افغانستان ولكن
القضيه اين القضيه بان ضيفك الكريم يدافع
عن القيم الغربيه انا لا اتحدث من قام
بغزو العراق ليست فقط امريكا يا اخي قامت
هناك 33 دوله غربيه بغزو العراق ركض
كالعمياء وراء امريكا وخرج نعلم بان خرج
وزير الدفاع لنقل كانت ادلتنا كاذبه لقد
كذبنا عندما قلنا بان اصلح الدمار شامل في
العراق الكارثه الاسد في امريكا يا في
امريكا معروفه تاريخها هذه الدوله قامت
على جثث الهنود الحمر قامت على قتل السكان
الصين الا اتحدث عنها الدوله انا اتحدث عن
دول غربيه تدعي بانها لديها اقم انسانيه
عندما عندما تقوم بريطانيا يا اخي
بريطانيا تنتقم بريطانيا تقوم رئيس وزراء
بريطانيا ويقول لك نحن اخطانا بحق
العراقيين نحن من اوجدنا التنظيمات
الارهابيه نحن من سعينا الى انهيار الشرق
الاوسط انا لا اتحدث
ان اقوله لك فقط نقطه هامه باختصار فرنسا
بالنسبه الى المهاجرين المهاجرين الذين
اتى منهم المهاجرين الذي اتى منهم اا من
بلد ضيفه الكريم في فرنسا من من الجزائر
والمغرب الم نراهم
باي كلام نرى بانهم شاركوا بتظاهرات الستر
الصفراء وكيف قام البوليس الفرنسي برشا
بالماء الساخنه وبالهراوات الم نرى بان
الاضطرابات الاخيره التي قامت به نقابات
الفرنسيه عندما قامت السلطات الفرنسيه
باستدعاء الشرطه الى بيوت هؤلاء النقابيل
واستدعاءهم الى العمل من اجبار دون ان
تلبي طلبات النقابه علما بان يفترض هناك
الغرب لديه قيم اخلاقيه والنقابات هناك
مستقله لا تقوم بتاديه ادوارها اذا اذا
لديها دور فاعل في المجتمع
اذا لا تحدث عن القيم الغربيه جميل جدا
دكتور دكتور في الفلاني ذاته يعني لماذا
لا نقول في في المقابل ان روسيا ليست
راعيه للارهاب من روسيا ضحيه للارهاب ضحيه
للارهاب يعني البعض يقول لك من الذي
استهدف خط الغاز نور ديسترين
اليسوا الارهابيين او الارهابيين الذين
فعلوا ذلك يعني هذا خط خط تجاري
الاعتداء على هذا الخط الم يكون عملا
ارهابيا الاعتداء على ال- ال- الجسور بين
القرموكرانيا ليس عملا ارهابيا اعتداءات
كثيره روسيا في واقع الامر هي ضحيه كما
كما يقول البعض وليس العكس
دكتور فيصل انظر انت عندما تدخل الى
اوكرانيا وتخزوا دوله وتدمر شعبها وترحلها
فان الشعب الاوكراني لديه كل
ما يفعل نفسه بتدمير اي منشاه للغازي هذا
منطق الحرب هذا من ناحيه عندما تقول ياما
روسيا ضحيه لعمليه الارهابيه لا تنسى انه
في تاريخ العمليات الارهابيه التي حدث بما
في ذلك داخل روسيا كشفت المخابرات وتحقيق
انه قام بها جهاز المخابرات الروسي وقتها
ما بيهششانيين او الداغستانيين او
القوقازيين لكي يشرع عمليه ابادتهم وقتلهم
يعني العمليه روسيا هي صانعه مصنعه
الارهاب انا لا اتعرف على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي اليه الارهاب في العالم وه
ذا رجل الحلقه اليوم عروسه
قامت بقتل الشعر السوري وذبحت ثوره ليبيا
وساهمت في دعم المجرم خليفه حفتر وقتل
سكان ليبيا وسلل ضواحي جنوب طرابلس ماذا
حدث فيهم 2019 يعني القول بانها ضحيه امر
مبالغ فيه امام بالنسبه للقيمه الغربيه
الثامنه الاولى المتوسط الوصول الى هذه
الضاحيه بروسيا التي احاديه التي هي
الوريث الشرعي والطبيعي لجرائم الاتحاد
الذي نشا على جماجم القوميات القوقازيه
التي لا يذكرها احد اليوم
وسلسبيل يوم على قناه سيبيريا اليوم ورثت
عصابه لجرشيه على الحكم وتريد بهذا
البروتين يريد همم يعني بهذا الشكل ان
نعيد
العظمه الروسيه وعظمه الامبراطوريه لانها
وقع اوكراني
لا يمكن ان يواصل هكذا
الادمير دولته الحين ان الشعب الروسي في
معظمه هذه الحركه وتذكر فيصل عندما طلب
ولم
يفنى التجنيد الاجباري كيف امتلات
المطارات بالرؤوس هاربين من مغامرات هذا
المغامر الاحمر الذي يقول البلد الى مزيد
ان تعرف ولا مزيد قال انهيار يعني اليوم
كان نائم قلب السحر على الساحر خرجت
امريكا من افغانستان دليله خاسره اليوم
سيخرج للاتحاد السوفيتي القطبيه هذه
الاقرب الكبرى في الحرب البارده ويمكن
لشعوب ان تتنفس بعد من الحريه نتمنى كذلك
ثوره الشعب الايراني
كذلك ان تصنع الجماهير
يكون فيه الارهاب موجه نحو العصابات
الحاكمه هو رؤوس الاموال وصانعي الاسلحه
ونجري انمار
بالهام
الابراج
جميل جدا ما كان بشار الاسد قام قوسين او
ادنى من السقوط 2015 الجلاء هو الطي
ران بقى ثوره شعب سوريا
سوري خارج سوريا
وضد اطفال
مفرتهم وصنعت من المذابح ما لم يصنعه احد
في التاريخ جميل جدا دكتوره في هذا الاطار
في هذا الاطار القرار الاوروبي بتصنيف
روسيا دوله راعيه للارهاب جاء عقب
الاستهداف الروسي للبنيه التحتيه للاحياء
المدنيه للمدن في اوكرانيا للمدن في
اوكرانيا هل تستطيعين ان تنكري ان الجيش
الروسي وميليشيات روسيا اصبحت مختصه منذ
سنوات فقط في احراق المدن والمدنيين
وتشريد وتهجير المدنيين في سوريا دكتوره
الجميع يعلم لم تترك مدرسه لم تترك مسجدا
لم تترك مجنه للطيور لم تترك اي شيء مدني
الطائرات الروسيه الا ودمرته فوق رؤوس
اصحابه واليوم تفعل شيء نفسها في في
اوكرانيا يعني صحيح ان اوروبا تركت الحبل
على الغرب للروس كي يفعل ما يشاؤون في في
سوريا لكن الان واصبح السيف فوق رؤوس
الشكر في اوكرانيا تحرك الاوروبيون لكن لا
باس لا باس كما يقول الدكتور كيف تردين
الوقت دعمنا
نعم دكتور فيصل نعم انا ساستشهد بمساله خط
نوردز ستريم الذي تم تحطيمه هل كان هذا
المساله ضد روسي ام ضد اوروبا
هنا المخابرات الاوكرانيه هل وجهت هذه
الضرب من روسيا روسيا تستورد الغاز من
اوروبا يا دكتور محمد هل روسيا مثل الغاز
هل اوروبا الان بريطانيا تقوم الان بتقنين
الكهرباء وتوعد المواطنين البريطاني بين
ستطلس عدد ساعات الاناره نتيجه هذه العمل
هي هي من من من يحق لها ان تقوم
بتحطيم خط نور سليم مساله الحبوب التي
اخرجتها روسيا من الموانئ ويفطر ان تذهب
الى الدول الفقيره ان لم تذهب الى الدول
الغنيه الم تقوم روسيا الان بتوزيع
على الدول افريقيا
اقوى من المجار
انتهى باختصار شديد باختصار شديد اريد ان
انهي الحلقه بس يا دكتوره خلص الوقت والله
العظيم خلص الوقت دكتور بدي جمله منك
جمله من الدكتور بدي ارجعلك بدي يرجع لك
بس نقطه تفضلوا تفضلي
طيب تفضلي سوريا شو بدك تحكي اتفضل
الى سوريا الان وانظر الى سوريا قبل
الثورات الملونه هي من جره ال- ال- الشعوب
انا ذهبت الى سوريا والله لم اجد سوريا
الشعب السوري الان ليس لديه ماء ولا
كهرباء الشعب السوري الان في في عزه
الشتاء لا يملك طاقه الشمس السوري ان
يعاني من المجاعه نتيجه التجويع الاوروبي
العقوبات على الاوروبيه ولا العقوبات
الامريكيه ما تشتكي الشعب السوري من من من
الحكم وانما هي عباره يعني يا دكتور فيصل
المساله هي الدوره على الدول هي المساله
بالدور وسيئه الدوله
لكن الدوله
الوقت للاسف الشديد دكتور باختصار شديد
جمله واحده يعني هل تعتقد ان هذا القرار
خلينا نجمل هذا القرار الاوروبي سيكون في
مصلحتنا يعني بطريقه او باخرى
باختصار بجمله واحده
لانه يخرج
تهم يتدخل الارهاب الروسي لقتل السوريين
الى كانت اليوم سوريا دوله في طريقه نحو
الحريه ونحو الديمقراطيه ولما قتل وشرد
ولفى ودفن من الاحرار والمجاهدين السوريين
ما قتله المجرم بشار الاسد
على راسي يا عم ده حزب الله من لبنان
اشكرك جزيل الشكر مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى
لنا اشكرك اضيفاتنا من روسيا همم الدكتوره
الدكتوره الدكتوره ثريا الفره ومن باريس
الدكتور محمد هنيدي نلتقي مساله الاتان
مقبل فحتى ذلك الحين وفيصل القاسم يحييكم
من الدوحه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]